what are we doing today well we've got
the Rick mobile out and people I think
are going to be coming and coming and
buying some paraphernalia
hey everyone its ash downtown LA and
right behind me yeah you might recognize
that it's the RIC mobile it's been
touring all over the US but it's finally
come here exclusive merchandise fans
have been lining up for hours and hours
and hours and Chris Parnell the voice of
Jerry is here there is a big line okay I
think people slept here maybe there
really yes they're in like camping
chairs I saw people asleep we've got
some great fans so season three is
finally here are you do you have like
such a sense of relief to of people that
have been asking and asking and asking
at every interview I do also just I'm
excited to see it you know because I
haven't seen anything but the first one
they ran on April Fool's
so I forget a lot of it after I do it I
forget most of it so when I'm watching
them it's kind of all new to me a whole
new experience what can you tease for us
for Jerry for season three well it's
it's kind of dark times for Jerry and
some somewhat for Beth as well I think
but they're separated and Jerry is
living on his own at a certain point and
you know he has just one episode where
he has a great adventure with the rigs
not quite as heavy of a Jerry season
yeah I was gonna say is Jerry ever
getting Conad adventure with Rick
excited he does he does it's it's a good
it's a good one too now with Beth and
Jerry being separated I mean do you
think that Jerry is still thinking about
sleepy Gary I'm sure he is I'm sure he
is he can't shake Gary you know how
could you it was such an experience is
mr. Cooby butthole coming back wouldn't
be surprised if he does but I I wouldn't
be surprised if he doesn't either I
missed him dearly how do you think he's
doing
I think he's always great I think he
care of himself have you tried Szechuan
sauce I haven't no I miss I don't think
I have anyway certainly not the Szechuan
sauce that's being referred to I heard I
heard a rumor that they sent you guys
like McDonald's sent you guys the
remaining supply of it or something
that's true I doubt if that's true I
think it would be way out of date by now
yeah oh not good
no probably not edible so maybe that's
false I think you just made that up mate
maybe it's a really good show that I'm
proud to be on because it's such good
writing it's funny and I love to sci-fi
and then Justin's brilliant Dan's
brilliant you know that's good it's good
to like your job it is good it is good I
really and I really enjoy watching it
and I feel like I have to ask what
happened to your arm yeah yeah no I had
I had rotator cuff surgery okay very
sexy sexy injury ladies like